من بيروت معنا العبيد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك العميد
الياس حنا ماذا عن هذا المعطى الجديد وهنا
يعني تحديدا التجربه بصواريخ زركون ماذا
كيف نفهمها في ظل المعادله الاوسع
عبد القادر المنظومه الكبيره هي منظومه
متكامله تبدا من البعد التكتيكي على سبيل
المثال من سوليدار
الى البعد الاستراتيجي العملاني والتي يجب
ان تحمي برادع معين عندما نرى جورج كو في
بحر النروج
تجربكم انما هي تقول انه لدى همم روسيه
امكانات لضرب كل الدول التي تتبع الناته
او التي تدعم اوكرانيا انه راجع انه من
ضمن المنظومه انها رساله ولكن هذا الامر
لا يفيد كثيرا الموضوع التكتيكي على
الساحه الاساسيه اللهم الا اذا وصلنا الى
مرحله العوده وبدات الحرب بشكل مختلف
باستعمال اسلحه ذا دمار شامل يتعلق فقط
العنيد الياس حنا به الصواريخ همم
التحذيرات الروسيه تتعلق ايضا بملف
الدبابات والان اصبح تزويد الغرب
لاوكرانيا بالدبابات
او لبرد اقرب من اي وقت مضى لكنهم ما الذي
سيغيره في معادله هذه الحرب
اذا اتت حاملات الجنب مدرعه
المدرعات من برادلي وماردر الامريكيه
والالمانيه واذا استكملت بدبابات كما يقال
بالانجليزيه مين تانك باتل التي تحمل
المدفع الذي هي قادره على الق- ال- ال-
التامين الدعم الناري واستكملت مع دفاعات
جويه قد يشكل هذه المنظومه همم قدره
هجوميه قد تخرج الدفاعات الروسيه وبالتالي
تحديد الواقع الاهم هو شبه جزيره القرم
واقليم قدهم بس وهذا امر يعتبر تبوك كما
يقال محرم لدى القوات الروسيه هذا الامر
سيغير المعادله على الارض ولكن يبقى ما هو
عدد الدبابات لهبار ما هو عدد دبابات الام
والابرامز او تشالنجر الامريكيه همم
الانجليزيه ومتى ستكون جاهزه بالمرحله
القادمه هل يمكن القول العبيد يستحنا ان
هذه اول مره تتم فيها هذه المواجهه
هذا المستوى هنا اعني ابرام زواري بارد من
جهه والدبابات الرؤوس الصناعه صناعه
الدبابات الروسيه من جهه اخرى في بيئه
خاصه كالتي هي في اوكرانيا
عبد القادر هي جريت في حرب الخليج يعني
الدبابات من صنع سوفيتي كان العراق
يمتلكها
انزلت الام والابلانس خسائر كبيره بهذا
الموضوع وقد تستعمل بحرب سيكولوجيه في
المرحله القادمه هذه الدبابات هي اكثر
تدريعا هي اكثر قوه هي ترمي على مسافات
بعيده هذا الامر يعطيها هامش منها الامان
هي جربت اليوم يبقى دائما عبد القادر ليس
بما تملك من سلاح ولكن في كيفيه الاستعمال
لهذا السلاح تكتكيا اثبت الجيش الاوكراني
قدره هائله في هذا الموضوع روسيا في
الفتره الاخيره لم تتوقف عن التحدير للدول
الحديثه لاوكرانيا وتلك التي تزودها
بالاسلحه ان كانت دفاعيه وفي القريب
العاشر ستكون همم هجوميه هل يمكن ان تتعدى
حدود هذه الحرب نطاق اوكرانيا
ازدهار حسب الواقع الميداني هل فعلا سيكون
هناك هزيمه كبيره او نكره للجيش الاوكراني
على الروسي على سبيل المثال تهديد شبه
جزيره قلم والتي تعتبر الحصه الكبيره من
مشروع الرئيس بوتين على هذا الامر يتعلق
التصعيد ولكن التصعيد حتى الان هو تصعيد
مضبوط ضمن خطوط معينه وضعها الرئيس بايدا
في بدايات الحرب لا لعسكري يقاتل على
امريكا يقاتل على الصحه الاوكرانيه لا
لسلاح هجومي يهدد الارض الاوكرانيه
الروسيه اليوم السلاح الهجومي هو سلاح
الهجومي في داخل اوكرانيا ولا يمكن له ان
يكون هجوميا على الارض الروسيه شكرا اذا
لك من بيروت العمليات الخبير العسكري